accounting is really really important
okay a lot of accounting has its
reputation as a back office being
counting introverted profession but it's
actually the language of business right
so businesses communicate internally
they communicate with investors or
shareholders with the markets through a
language that language is accounting
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm being
joined today by isaac heller ceo of
trulian an ai-powered sas platform that
automates financial workflows for cfos
accountants and auditors trillion
unifies the unstructured and structured
worlds of accounting by reading pdfs and
excel and translating them into
financial workflows such as lease
accounting and revenue recognition
isaac heller welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from dallas texas
how are you
good i mean it's usually it's all the
way from israel but i'm in dallas texas
this week
i love it and so i'm thankful to be
catching in dallas texas that it's
adding to the globalization of of the
show and today you're thinking through
rigorously this idea of modern
accounting and where we're at and with
your startup truly on but you have a you
know you have a really interesting
background leading up to it you know
starting all the way from being an
english teacher in china and to
being in saber corporation
vp at visual lease and a member of the
forbes technology council
and so it's a lot of different things
that that i didn't even touch on but
but what i'm really curious to hear here
is you know people's journeys what
really motivates them and how they end
up
coming to to start what they start and
so maybe you can go back a little bit in
time and tell me more briefly about
yourself and and how and how you end up
deciding to work on modern accounting
uh this is a 20-minute podcast uh so
basically
look i i studied history at the
university of texas i asked the history
teacher what should i do after college i
i had an interview lined up for dell
sales in austin texas it was 2007. he
said you should go to a hyper growth
economy and just live there and so i
looked up china china was booming right
then it was 2007 and i went and taught
english in china i went there
um spent a year there teaching english i
actually played a little bit of poker in
macau it was quite a year
and then
yeah i mean i went into i went into the
travel industry i knew i liked two
things travel and basketball so i found
a travel agency that did basketball
tours and i went around the world with
college basketball teams
both men's and women's from duke to
north carolina to princeton i was in
australia i was in senegal i was in
brazil with these teams i had a great
time
um yeah and then
one day i was looking over the shoulder
it was really a travel agency that's
what it was i was looking over the
shoulder at one of the travel agents and
they were working on this kind of blue
screen it looked like it was ms-dos if
you if you if you can go that far back
and i said what's that they said that's
the technology we use
turned out that that company was called
sabre
and that was a travel technology company
that was down the street in south lake
texas so i said well that that seems
interesting
so i knew i liked travel but then i
ended up in technology and then once i
was in travel technology this is sabre
saber owned travelocity did a lot of
work with expedia
uh and then ipo'd in 2014 so i was i was
part of that
and incredible then i realized well i
don't just love travel i love technology
okay so that got me into technology at
the same time i did an mba my history
degree wasn't paying the bills and so i
thought i'd learn some business i fell
in love with accounting i love the logic
i love the the theory of it
and just kept running into huge
accounting projects in what's called
revenue
recognition and lease accounting i ran a
product team in the travel industry that
did
revenue accounting for airlines which is
a crazy complex accounting world and so
i guess you could say the accounting
gods
were kind of keeping me close
and and after that after seeing some
cool opportunities feeling very
passionate about a specific industry i
went off
and and founded the company with with a
great partner and a great team and
that's where we are today
so accounting what what is the
understanding of accounting and how does
that lead to trillion
okay first of all
accounting is really really important
okay a lot of accounting has this
reputation as a back office being
counting introverted profession
but it's actually the language of
business right so businesses communicate
internally they communicate with
investors with shareholders with the
markets through a language that language
is accounting so first of all that's
pretty interesting right second of all
the industry itself the way it's set up
is a little bit antiquated so there's
there's legacy silos
when you when you audit a company when
you do a financial audit
you might be sampling
one out of a thousand
contracts or transactions just to
provide your evidence that it's it's so
so-and-so audited so you have a really
important industry
really big opportunity to improve and
innovate within the area
and uh you know decided to have some fun
so so you've been having fun of the last
two years and as you're starting truly
on what are some of the guiding
principles that that you're thinking
through when modernizing the accounting
world
well i think it starts with the name
right so trulian is truth in millions it
means something it means something to me
personally it means something to our
company and we're founded on these
principles of accuracy and transparency
right so that's what people pay for you
know some some industries they pay for
increased revenue or reduced costs in
accounting the value is transparency and
accuracy
and that that guides us every day in
what we do and and so how does that
actually translate into
first of all what does the product
actually do and then how does accuracy
and transparency translate into this
product
okay so so truly in itself
takes unstructured data so think about
documents in excel and it extracts it
automatically and generates financial
workflows these are the workflows that
that people use to do their day-to-day
accounting for example lease accounting
revenue recognition these are critical
workflows to get financial reporting
accurate and so what's unique is that
trulian connects it with the source data
so you could take a pdf and then do a
workflow and bring it to the final entry
now that's that's cool that could save a
controller a lot of time but what's
interesting is now that the source data
is connected with financial entry their
auditor or
accounting partner can come in and see
the entry all the way back to the source
data right that creates a new uh
paradigm within the industry right and
why is that more accurate well you have
the entire audit trail at your
fingertips so before
you know you're uh you're a cfo or
controller and you're doing a lot of
these processes in a spreadsheet
okay or a disconnected system and then
once a month or once a year you're
pushing that into a bigger system like
an erp right this is anything from
quickbooks to sap
and
and then what happens is when an order
comes in they have to look into that big
system
they have to take a few samples they
have to swim into that spreadsheet from
that spreadsheet they have to swim back
into source data source documents hey
who who put this in who approved it
where'd they get the data from with
truly and you have that all in one
unified workflow
okay and science are what what are some
of the personas that are relevant for
for for products and these and my my
knowledge of accounting is so minimal so
i'm going to be asking a lot of these
questions
well it's interesting there's a lot of
people who you know look michael you
live in the
hyper growth startup world right even
even hippo where you're working i'm sure
it was just like a rocket ship right
straight to the moon and so a lot of
people that work in these worlds
they that's more the the startup where
accounting isn't as important you know
we're we're coming up with arbitrary
valuations and metrics based on a lot of
uh different factors but in the
accounting world and the audited world
these um these things really matter so
that's that's the world that we play now
who does that translate to it's called a
controller right it's a corporate
controller
someone who is strictly in charge of
financial reporting and compliance for
the organization those are our customers
those are our innovators and that's we
work with
now obviously you know we started the
conversation by by by talking about how
there's a lot of incumbents and a lot of
these legacy systems and you're coming
in you're modernizing it but but but the
other aspect of what we're saying is
that there's a lot of trust that needs
to be maintained and there needs to be
upheld with with the customers and
you're dealing obviously with sensitive
data and with financial reporting so how
do you go as a startup and go and
attempt to build trust that is at least
as great as those incumbents
wow um
look i i don't think that we can be
greater
than the incumbents and towards its or
in terms of trust so meaning the people
that we work with
is sap and oracle and ernst young and
pwc like that's our world right we can't
be
better than them right those are the
those are the iconic brands and those
are the thought leaders in this
industries
what we can do is we can complement them
right so in this space you have
new regulations that come in for example
lease accounting and revenue recognition
and those
those providers may not have an adequate
solution for that right and it may be
done in spreadsheets outside of their
workflow whether it's sap or a big4
company so we can do is we can fill in
that gap with automation
and and how i mean how do they get
comfortable with us well look we're a
bunch of cpas and product experts i i
lived through revenue recognition i
lived through lease accounting standards
the people that we hire
they've lived through this as well so
the first thing we do
is we make sure
that the accounting is bulletproof and
accurate you know we're not one of these
startups that puts out an mvp and then
you know kind of teases it out right we
paid with our angel money we paid for a
kpmg sock one and stock two report you
know that's like wow that's like the the
thing that everything's avoiding so you
know for us this is our world we invest
in compliance and accuracy from day one
right now i'm curious to hear hear you
know the breaking into the market so and
you know anytime i get i get to meet a
company that is dealing with it within
you know age old industry that has you
know a lot of traditional players and
and that that is innovating at a
different rate you know what is how do
you actually go about you know getting
people involved in this you know i
understand the building the trust aspect
but but getting them to actually request
a demo to actually go through the
pipeline and to see the value of your ai
powered system
okay well first of all in all of these
industries
there's this like secret
um unspoken club or like underbelly
of
personas
who want innovation they desperately
crave innovation okay and it's not
unique to our space it's every single
space so how did we get our first few
customers
we took out a linkedin ad and we said ai
powered you know lease accounting right
and and from there we had these
controllers in australia and europe and
brazil everywhere who requested a demo
and we said whoa okay well they're
interested and they said yeah i mean
we're doing this in spreadsheets and
this looks really interesting
and then we offered to let them put um
a couple of contracts in our system we
said just put upload the your contracts
into our system
and you can have we'll give you the
report that we put out and so they take
that report back and they match it
against their spreadsheet they say whoa
wait a minute this is doing it
and that's it so they find out about and
they're a little bit hesitant okay i
didn't hear about this from you know my
my accounting partner but then they test
it and they like it and they these are
clients that are signing multi-year
deals with us right this isn't we're not
an mvp we're not a beta these are people
that are passing big four audits with us
at this point
right so if you see if you had to you
know go down the line two three years
what where where's truly on in the space
well where's the modern accounting in
general
um well i think it's more dynamic right
so it's more event-driven workflow-based
i think that
accounting is stuck between static
repositories right which might be a
legacy erp system
and
really really strong incredible
accounting firms
but they're services oriented right and
so neither of those two pillars
iconic pillars of this ecosystem can
create
digital or dynamic workflows right so
what that means is we can take
unstructured data we can connect it with
a financial workflow
you know layer on reporting analytics
360 degree audit trail
you know when i think about trulian you
know we're the single source of truth
right we want to continue to play in
these areas
where
those providers don't adequately address
and connect some of these silos for our
clients
right now is this really where where
your passion lies in in accounting is
this is you know growing up is this sort
of did you understand that this is what
you want to be doing this is going to be
your entrepreneurial journey
i don't know
like it's funny i'm sitting in dallas
right now this is this room is a home
office now post covid but this is
actually the room that i grew up in and
i used to collect
trading cards i used to collect
basketball and football and baseball
cards
and i would i would sell them on ebay i
would buy big boxes i would break them
apart i would get a bunch of packaging
supplies sent to our house and i was
like one of the early kind of ebay
people so looking back i guess i was
kind of an entrepreneur but i worked
throughout corporate america i worked in
private equity back companies so i had
my own journey i never did my own thing
the the common theme i would say like if
you if you look back in my career
is truth seeking okay also my personal
uh passion like it's true seeking you
know i was one of these guys who
my mom would say
uh isaac uh that's not fair life's not
fair you know and i would say well i'm
gonna fix that or i'm gonna make sure
that's fair i'm gonna make sure that's
right right so i wouldn't accept that
for an answer so when i think about
accounting accounting is about
transparency and accuracy so when i see
these
um
big audit
issues like like a company
like wirecard for example in germany
there was a two billion dollar cash
asset that was missed by the auditors
for repeated years that just didn't
exist okay and my friend's grandmother
had that stock in her pension portfolio
she's she's very modest middle class so
for me like i actually get fire out of
that i don't know if anyone else does
but like that motivates me that pumps me
up and and i really see this this truth
seeking
um you know theme throughout my personal
and professional life
wow very very cool isaac thank you so
much for coming in and sharing your
journey with me i really appreciate it
i have a few more questions a few more
small questions about you and i want to
take you back back to your childhood as
you're in your childhood you know i
guess room and and
and and house you know what really
fascinated you besides besides ebay what
really you know drove your curiosity you
know middle school high school what do
you remember
oh oh good one okay i i mean what drove
my curiosity let's say anything new
okay
guy was the guy with like the first mp3
pet player all the little things
anything new
um
anything
related to basketball really drove me
and lastly like anything competitive i
mean i just i remember like having
decathlons with my friends where we
would line up like 10 different sports
everything from chess to nfl blitz on
nintendo 64. and we would just put a big
board up and just go to town you know
for the medal
amazing and what inspires you today in
your daily life
um
i mean my family you know i've got a
wife and two daughters and so that that
inspires me you know i want to make it
good for them and i want to kind of
infuse
the values they get from the home into
the professional world and the things i
learned from the professional or from a
leadership perspective i want to help
you know bring those into the home
um and that's it like we you know as a
as a fast-growing startup like we have
the opportunity to
like make these new friendships and and
um open up roles for other people and
build partnerships and you know our
company like we really feel that as like
a family as well so that that motivates
me to have these personal relationships
through the the professional
you know um vessel
very very cool and isaac what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
um energized
curious
and
relentless
i love it isaac thank you very very much
best of luck with trillian thank you for
sharing this time with me i appreciate
it very much all right
okay well thanks michael
[Music]